Everyone loves a hero story.
It's satisfying to
see good overcome evil
and then ride off
blissfully into the sunset.
But there's a long history
of stories with heroes
who don't get their
happily ever after.
According to Aristotle,
the function of these so-called
tragic heroes was to provide
a catharsis or a release of
emotions for the audience
when a fatal character flaw
led to the hero's
untimely demise.
The tragic hero is
meant to be the face
of a cautionary tale,
but Irish folklore offers
an interesting take
on this classic archetype
in the story of Cu Chulainn,
a gifted warrior who
knew from childhood
that he would live a
short but legendary life.
[whimsical music]
Cu Chulainn is considered by
many to be the greatest hero
in Irish mythology
with only one real
rival for the top spot,
the hunter Fionn mac Cumhaill.
Most of our knowledge of
these and other figures
from Celtic folklore
come from records
taken by Christian monks in
the 11th and 12th centuries.
Before that, the people
we now call the Celts,
thanks to ancient Greeks,
were an oral society.
They passed knowledge from
one generation to the next
in the form of stories,
poems, or songs
that were recited
and memorized.
The Celts were a collection
of culturally similar
but independent tribes
who traveled from the Alps
around 1200 BCE and spread
across much of Western Europe
by the third century BCE.
Rome conquered much of
Europe two centuries later,
but the northern parts that
became Ireland, Scotland,
and Wales remained
mostly unbothered
for another several
hundred years.
The monks' records
don't reveal too much
about Celtic societies,
and it's impossible to say how
their Christian perspective
influenced the
writing we do have,
but we know that the Celts
understood astronomy,
respected nature, and
valued cattle so highly
that wars were often
fought as cattle raids
or one-on-one duels
between champions.
Remember that because
it will come up later.
Modern scholars have divided
the stories from these records
into four roughly
chronological cycles:
Mythology, Ulster,
Fenian, and Historical.
Each cycle is full of
really interesting stories,
and if you want to learn about
some of the Mythology Cycle,
check out the "Monstrum"
episode on Celtic fairies.
Woo.
But here, we'll focus
on the Ulster Cycle,
which is set around
the time of Christ
and heavily features the life
of the warrior Cu Chulainn.
Born with the name Setanta,
anyone could tell
Cu Chulainn was destined to
be a hero from the beginning
simply because his
birth was so remarkable.
Cu Chulainn's mother was
a woman named Deichtine,
the sister
of Conchobar mac Nessa,
king of Ulster, or Ulaid,
the region of Northern Ireland
for which the folkloric
cycle is named.
Setanta's father was
the sun god Lugh,
one of the mythical
Tuatha De Danann.
There are multiple versions
of Setanta's birth story.
In one, Deichtine and her
handmaidens are whisked away
on the eve of her wedding
to the mystical Otherworld,
where she accidentally
drinks a tiny version of Lugh
and becomes pregnant.
In another, Cu Chulainn
is conceived thrice.
At first,
he was born to a woman
who Deichtine
helped through labor
thanks to Lugh's interference,
but he died in childhood
as Deichtine's foster son.
Next, he was conceived
in a dream Deichtine had
of the sun god Lugh, but
she aborted the pregnancy
because she was married
to a mortal man.
Finally, Deichtine became
pregnant by her husband
and was urged by Lugh to
name the baby boy Setanta.
When Setanta was
a young boy, around six,
in most versions of the tale
he earned himself a new name.
He traveled with
his family to the home
of the blacksmith
Culann for a feast
where he was separated
from the group
and came face-to-face with the
smith's vicious guard hound.
Despite his youth,
Setanta defeated the hound
and then promised to act
as the smith's new
guard dog in recompense.
Thus Cu Chulainn, or Culann's
Hound, was born again.
The next year, Cu Chulainn
overheard a prophecy
spoken by his maternal
grandfather, the Druid Cathbad.
It said that anyone who
took up arms on that day
would have eternal fame,
but live a short life.
Cu Chulainn approached
the king that very day
and asked to begin
his warrior training,
thus sealing his fate.
Cu Chulainn was sent to Scotland
to train with the
renowned fighter Scathach,
who gifted him his
legendary spear Gae Bulg,
which could travel
at lightning speeds
and shoot 30 little
barbs from its tip.
Cu Chulainn was
naturally strong and fast
thanks to his divine parentage,
but while he was away
he really learned the
ways of both war and love.
He even sired a son, whom he
later accidentally killed,
by Scathach's daughter
despite the fact
that he was betroth to
a woman back in Ireland.
By the time he returned
to his homeland,
Cu Chulainn was a young man
often described as short
and notably beardless
with fuzzy hair.
Though it was said that
the women of Ulster
were driven mad
with lust for him.
As perhaps the most skilled
of the king's Red
Branch warriors,
it was Cu Chulainn's
responsibility
to protect his land and people.
Whenever his strength,
speed, and training
weren't enough to defeat a foe,
Cu Chulainn relied
on his special power
called the riastrad.
Much like a Norse berserker,
Cu Chulainn could
change form in battle.
He grew to nine feet tall
and one of his eyes
either bulged
or rolled back in his head
and a haze of blood appeared
around his fuzzy mane.
When Cu Chulainn was in this
state, he was invincible
and so enraged he couldn't
tell friend from foe.
No one was safe from his ire,
and it was nearly impossible
to bring him back to normal.
Upon returning home from a
particularly violent mission,
Cu Chulainn, still
gripped by the riastrad,
demanded to be given
an opponent to fight
or else he would kill everyone
in the entire fortress.
Instead of offering up
a victim,
the leaders of Ulster sent
out a group of naked women.
Cu Chulainn was so
embarrassed by the sight
that he averted his gaze,
giving the other warriors
time to restrain him
and dunk him in water
until he calmed down.
The people of
Ulster were grateful
for Cu Chulainn's
murderous rage, however,
when their kingdom was invaded
by the army of Connacht's
warrior queen Medb.
Remember when Moiya told
you cattle were valuable
in ancient Celtic societies?
Well, Medb's master plan was
to amass empire-building wealth
by stealing Ulster's prize bull.
On the day of the attack,
all of the soldiers in
Ulster's army were struck down
by a curse that gave
them menstrual pangs
and prevented them
from fighting.
To that I say two things.
One, this wouldn't have happened
if you had more women warriors
who already knew how to
fight through the pain.
And two, it was
Cu Chulainn's time to shine.
In what became known as the
legendary Tain Bo Cuailnge,
or the Cattle Raid of Cooley,
17-year-old Cu Chulainn
single-handedly fought off
Medb's army one soldier
at a time for days
until the rest of the
Ulster men recovered enough
to back him up.
Medb's army was
forced to retreat,
but it wouldn't be
their last invasion
of Cu Chulainn's home.
In a classical tragedy,
this would be about the time
that Cu Chulainn would be lured
from the path of greatness
by his fatal flaw.
He would demonstrate
too much hubris
or get caught up in a
web of his own lies.
But instead of a fatal flaw,
it's something called a geis
that leads to
Cu Chulainn's demise.
Geasa are taboos, or curses,
or can even be seen as
gifts bestowed upon people
by their parents, a Druid, or
some other authority figure.
To break a geis is to bring
about extreme misfortune.
Cu Chulainn's behavior was
constrained by two geasa.
He must accept any food
offered to him by a woman,
and he must not eat dog meat.
If you are familiar with
common folklore tropes,
you might be able to see
where these unfortunately
contradicting taboos
will lead our hero.
When Cu Chulainn
was 27 years old,
Queen Medb and one
of his other enemies,
Lugaid mac Con Roi,
invaded Ulster.
On his way to the battle,
Cu Chulainn was tricked
into accepting hound meat
from a group of women,
breaking one geis
to uphold another.
The strength and power
were immediately sapped
from his body and he was
made vulnerable to weapons.
Cu Chulainn was mortally
wounded in that battle
by one of Lugaid's spears,
but he didn't go
down without a fight.
In one last heroic move,
Cu Chulainn tied himself
to a standing stone and
faced down his opponents.
Even in death, his reputation
kept the other army at bay
for more than a day
until a raven landed on his
body and broke the illusion.
Cu Chulainn likely wasn't
based on a real person,
but the legendary figure
continues to inspire
and influence in
modern-day Ireland.
You can find murals and
statues dedicated to him
around the country,
and references to him
can be found in media
around the world,
like the popular myth-based
video game "SMITE."
In classical literature,
according to Aristotle,
tragic heroes were defined
by their fatal flaw
and untimely death.
One could argue that
Cu Chulainn fits this mold
and that his fatal flaws
were the hubris,
impulsivity, and desire for fame
that led him to fulfill
Cathbad's prophecy
at the age of seven.
(host 2)
But Cu Chulainn's death
wasn't too early at all.
He always knew his
days were numbered,
and he got exactly
the destiny he wanted.
He lived the rough-and-tumble
life of a warrior,
built a reputation as
a truly fearsome opponent,
and continued to live on
in national memory
for thousands of years.
Sorry Aristotle, but that
doesn't sound very tragic to me.
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.